do people deserve do women deserve
respect just for being women no no what
what do you so let's go here go around I
know we had some initial reactions but
start here and then go around and say
why I personally think not
um I think women nowadays tend to be
like
very feminist focused you know what I
mean they don't be thinking about the
men which like understandable were women
we think about ourselves that's that's
just life in my opinion
um I think where everything that's going
on in the world and everything that
you're expecting a lot for men a lot of
respect for men when they're not
bringing anything they just think you
know what he has money he's gonna have
me because of what I bring to the table
but what do you bring to the table
absolutely nothing you bring personality
and that's about it that's what I feel
like most of the women nowadays can
bring and women who are out here like
run their own business stuff like that
like go for you like I understand that
you're bringing other stuff to the table
then like building Empire together
that's fine no problem but for the women
who don't have stuff like that you think
men care about if women are building it
yeah
they don't care about yourself
um but for women I feel like women
really think that men care that they
have to have something you know when
that's not the truth at all okay what do
you think
I see you thinking over there she's like
she's not
um I feel like
try to speak into your mic just you know
I feel like women don't do not deserve
respect off the bat
I feel like you need to earn the respect
um however I feel like a certain level
of respect should be given to you sort
of immediately
um because you cannot respect someone if
they do not respect you
so I then feel like if a man doesn't
give you a certain level of respect you
can't respect him back and there's not
really going to be any respect in that
scenario
can I comment on that yeah do you think
that seedway like you're saying like if
a man can give do you not think it's
like the other way around in general
everyone men and women the respect
should be there straight away yeah if
you're focused with that person more you
obviously get more respect put into you
but I feel like with women it's kind of
like why would I give him respect when
he's done this and the other would they
have done this that in general and
they're expecting their respect straight
away straight off the bat and women
don't do that most times
I feel like generally
um women tend to respect men
more sorry women tend to respect men
more than
men tend to respect women off the bat
you think most women respect men
I'm gonna be careful with my words here
because I wouldn't say no most women
don't respect the the average guy but I
feel like more women respect men than
men would respect women off the bat
um what makes you say that
I'd say that
it's more like I feel like women need
men more than men sort of need women so
women are willing to give respect
immediately or give trust immediately
rather than the man trying to give it to
the woman because men I feel like men
sort of want to explore different women
so if that's if that's true like why do
we have phrase in society like men are
trash no matter the problem man stupid
man men are dumb men are idiots yeah I
feel but we don't have like you know I
mean well in my space of YouTube women
or [__] is a bit common but in the
general public and media it's it's
really nice and even even on the train
like you'll see um things that are signs
that call men predators on the two
periods
um I'd say I think our general society
as a whole right now is failing I think
you can say a lot of women are horse and
a lot of men are trash I feel like we're
in a society now that is favoring like
prostitution like modern prostitution to
the point where it's like women are not
even committed to this guy they just
want this guy for money and this man
wants this girl just because of her body
or her face like people are not actually
loving each other for who they are as a
person anymore do you think that's ever
happened
yeah I feel like the thing is I don't
like generalizing because I feel like
everyone's different so I I feel like
these relationships out there where they
don't care about how the other person
looks they care about that person as
that person like how that person acts
how that person is like how that person
makes them feel some people just
generally want women for status and for
that power you wait you think who
do you think that's the majority
I agree with you on status I don't know
about power I wouldn't say majority
um but I'd say I probably say more I
wouldn't say high value men but men that
perceive themselves as high value would
rather have a woman of
sort of higher
status or I wouldn't say status I
probably think status isn't the right
word but are you still going to say that
you would say the majority of women
respect most men or respect more men
than men do women because that was the
initial question yeah
um that I asked not the general again I
think I may be my but I might have
phrase that a bit wrong I feel like
women seek out men
like need men more than men would say
they need women yeah I think that's sort
of what I was trying to say there okay
go ahead okay so just to restate because
we didn't write down a rabbit hut a
little bit yeah um do do women deserve
respect just for being women correct
okay so
um I think yes not just because they're
women though but because we should all
give a basic level of respect to anybody
that we're meeting not because they're
just women or men we should respect each
other period so yes okay what do you
think
um I don't think they should get it just
for being women I think as Lauren said
it's just for being a person
um and you should respect them until
they give you a reason not to respect
them such as maybe they don't respect
their self and don't carry themselves in
a great way so maybe your respect level
would go down for them and that's okay
because that's your judgment on them
okay
yeah um respect to me is just is it's
genderless
um you know yeah I think everybody who
deserves a
um you know deserves respect and it's
all about what are you doing to remove
respect off of the actions that you that
you take
okay go ahead
oh I'll tell you the better question is
what what we what we defining as respect
respect disrespect value like uh that's
why I'm confused that because like see a
dog deserve respect so I don't think you
supposed to just disrespect nobody but
like what type of respect I guess my
question is more is respect to given or
is it earned
well I think it's both you get a basic
level of respect just for being a human
you know what I'm saying for not
disrespecting me like if you don't
disrespect me I'ma respect you because
you respecting me but if you disrespect
me
Melanie what do you think
um I I think recite the question because
I I like I lost like every women do
women deserve respect for being women no
like because you're born with a vagina
you know like what does that mean like I
mean it's just human anatomy and a lot
of women fight for they say respect me
for my mind respect me for my
accomplishments and we're just as equal
as men but then at the same time they'll
say because I'm a woman
born with a vagina I deserve respect
it's like it's it's a dichotomy it's
like double-minded and it's illogical
like you have to earn respect like if
you are everybody's not going to get the
same level of respect I do think there's
a for human nature yes but I think women
want a respect that they do not give to
men I think respect might be the wrong
word
and now maybe women looking to be valued
I do because you want to be valued just
because you're a woman well I think what
the question is getting at is
there's so many modern women today that
just call themselves a queen for
existing yeah and you give participation
trophies just based off of you having
okay
which is which is completely trash right
like and I think like you know we have a
society that panders to one gender so
much
um of course it's easy to accept your
your participation trophy for being a
queen but if you were if you were a
queen and you were doing unsavory things
during the night during the street time
activity I think you deserve less
respect for me and to be considering you
within a relationship
what would you define as a queen
or what do you mean by Queen when you
say that yeah so like Queen is earned
right like so if you think like the
concept of king and queen you know
um you know there's a history within
that
um I don't think a queen can be a queen
without a king I think that it is
necessary to have a king first that's
all um and within that um when we live
in a culture of many ish I miss
independent
all of this other all of these other
things that continue to put men down
um and then you meet with the
unrealistic standards of most most
modern women today there just seems to
be a complete like breakdown of society
and the things that are
um important within that so I think a
queen needs to have a king first and
foreign
[Music]
it's almost like we're brainwashed it's
almost like we've been brainwashed to
accept like the the nastiness of us of
society to say okay you're doing you're
you're half naked therefore I like that
and it's just so crazy and it's so
backwards that even dudes like that like
I I used to have guy friends in my life
that would feel like empowered if their
girlfriend wanted to go out and be like
half naked in the club and to me that's
just like it's so crazy because that to
me is not Queen Behavior that's not
marriageable Material
what do you guys think do women do I
just think um you have to respond it as
a woman that's my only view on it okay
what do you think I just think if you
don't respect a woman like it has to be
like a good reason behind it and I also
think sometimes if someone doesn't
respect you you don't really care like
you know like if someone doesn't respect
you
their opinion don't back maybe even the
whole society you should care yeah you
should care everybody their boobies out
and somebody's gonna say I don't like
you because you're showing all your
front and you're gonna say I don't care
what they say because their what their
opinion don't matter that's the problem
with Society because it doesn't care
people don't care what people think
about them you should care if you're out
there and you're acting whore-ish and
you're looking unladylike
and people are coming in and you're
trying to get a certain kind of man and
people are like slagging you off online
you should care turn it down I'm tired
of saying boobies boobies and butts and
fannies and everything's out there I'm
sick and tired of seeing it you also get
to choose who you follow and who you
don't follow on social media to though
so I do think like you know what's up
titties and bumps all the time of course
and as far as I'm concerned if you're
out there and like you're saying about
the question was about respect
how do you expect to get respect when
you're out there showing it you might
say oh I don't care but sooner or later
you're going to come to that age where
it's going to hit you and you're going
to care and no one ain't gonna give a
[__] because all your fannies and
titties are out there and they say do
you know what see you on that as well
it's mostly women that will push women
to do only fans and stuff like that as
well like no girl go get that bike go
get this but your man will be like I
don't want you to do it that's why you
don't listen to women that doesn't I 100
agree one million percent like women
will push you like go queen go do that
but at the end of the day you are losing
more respect for yourself by listening
to a woman telling you to go out and do
that thing that day wouldn't even do
themselves you know what I mean it's
kind of just pushing your morals just a
little bit back you know what I mean I
can't say much more of myself well I do
why do women push other women to do sex
work and um promiscuous activity when
the first thing that happens when a
woman's mad or she calls another girl
yeah no no and we get so offended by
that word as well when it's like you
don't have women because y'all don't
like each other exactly women don't like
each other y'all the meanest to each
other but then get put off on men oh men
say this or do that like we were talking
to this one girl outside in between the
last show she's talking about getting
something done on her body
and the girl body right just like it's
already fine I'm saying telling her like
baby you ain't gotta do none of that but
it's not really they're not doing it for
me and they're doing it for other women
you know what I'm saying I don't really
think it's for the women though it's
more for the man because it's a man that
want it no no no no no no no
he was talking about this Society being
brainwashed this Society has been very
much to the point where they think that
is normal and they think that is okay
but here's the thing I actually agree
with you I think they do do it for the
men but it's like sexual tension it's
not relationship attention so you can
kind of do a cheat code you can go get a
BBL get a nice body and you do get more
attention from men than if you're flat
right but here's the thing though it's
not no attention no no but but but
listen though but it goes so deeper
though because I know who you're talking
about and he has a great body yeah so
you got to think about how far down deep
that she is within watching the
Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazine
doesn't look good to a man and now she
wants to enhance it to look like Betty
Boop you know honestly I think it's
because we're lazy as women we don't
want to go to the gym
I'm just saying if you want to get
better then you go to the gym as a flat
woman
[Laughter]
I've known you why would you want gonna
get it done because what's her name's
got it done it looks great he must say
yeah it might look good in there but I
don't want that in my bed you know men
want it to look at yeah to um was it
just to add for one night to um
but they will not marry it they will not
settle down with somebody with a fake or
lips the eyebrows and if they do it
ain't gonna last I think the issue might
be as well that some girls see how other
girls get treated when they get all
these things done so maybe if they get
flown out or good treatment and then
they think when they're not getting
anything they think that they should do
that and then get the attention the
other girls get when actually they're
getting that attention maybe because the
guy is kind of doing something
transactional with them in a way like if
you're flying them out you might expect
something from them yeah and then other
girls want to do that to get the same
treatment women need to be honest to
women because I saw a girl I interviewed
a young lady and I was she had a she had
her butt down
for you I had a good old feel of it you
know
[Laughter]
I wanted to feel their breasts because
their breasts were fantastic
is she here tonight she had the best
price I've ever seen ever but when you
think about because the women are out
there and they don't think about the
pain you know the stuff when they get in
their lips it goes rock hard they have
to get it cut out but I looked at her
ass and I thought you've had have you
had your bum down she said yeah and I
said can I have a feel well you just and
I said you've got to save you like and
she said yeah because I had the fat
reduced like taking that fee and put in
there now women are going to go around
they're going to go and say yeah we've
had that butt done but it was a it
looked like an orange
you know it's just like an ordinary bump
it was nice completely shaped but it was
all it all said he like and I'm sure
that women are thinking about getting
their butt done they're not thinking I'm
gonna get so you like years ago I used
to get like lip gloss that used to like
Sting your lips and make them swell a
bit now you want to go and get it
injected why can I can I comment on that
right so it's it's this illusion that is
taking place so women to your point want
to do it because of the reactions they
see they're getting from men but at the
end of the day it's so much deeper than
that because their mindset is so twisted
and warped and their value is placed in
this is what I bring to the table and
this is what I need to get and so I can
go get a quick fix if I get my body done
I can go ahead and get you know my boobs
done my buddy my booty done and my lips
done and I'm gonna be able to pull this
attention from a guy not knowing that
that is not lasting that's not the
attention that you want he's not looking
for a wife in that and so by the time
you're in that position you have to
maintain it right so you are looking at
your competition for the girl who
influenced you in the first place to get
that done because now she has become
your competition because your mindset
delusionally you wanted the attention
that she got but in turn of that she's
become your competition and now you have
to compete with her and maintain it and
go get more injections and get a little
poke of Botox over and over when instead
of working on your character and going
and getting healing and doing the
internal work that has gone long term
make you wife material you became an
objective object for him well I think
that the issue is is that modern women
today don't want to be wife material
being white material is not cool for the
majority of them yeah that's very
submissive for women nowadays and now we
get into the real the real of the real
yeah okay because at the end of the day
you know whether or not you would get
something done with your body you should
say what are the results that I want in
life what are the results because men
have been telling you that getting
something done to that degree in that
extent does not make you more marriage
immaterial but you would rather though
but that's what I'm saying but then I
said yeah exactly they're not listening
to us but you would rather pay for the
short-term attention validation that you
see your home girls getting versus
putting the actual work in that guy say
that they're actually looking forward to
get the end result that you inevitably
want so you want to get your body done
in order to receive more eggplants
inside of you or do you want to work on
becoming more much more marriageable
material to get a man that is going to
provide protect
for you into the long term men change
their minds a lot as well about the body
preference before it was really Slim
girls with big boobs then it was the
massive bums and now men like just
naturally there's something right now
it's a society
what is deep down inside of you has
never changed what the men want
that no because it's been the same all
over the years the what the men has one
has never changed your body might change
but deep inside what the men want has
never changed you keep on changing the
outside when they may not give a [__]
about their eyes they won't keep us they
want to keep they want the inside to say
the same they want the inside like what
their granny had their great granny had
that is the kind of woman they want man
they don't really give a [__] about what
you look like outside so you might be
keeping up with the fashion but they
don't care they want the old school the
inside so me you might not never your
big old titties and your feet and your
big old ass but I can catch you around
with my flat breasts and my flat ass why
because I can cook clean and I'm
submissive and I can look I think you're
very lucky
it's not luck don't don't care no it is
because a lot it pisses me off when
people say look I didn't get like this
because of luck this is who I am this is
not bringing from man this is not
listening to stupid women this is
listening to older men older women that
support me this ain't got nothing to do
with luck this is doing hard work and
determination I'm not gonna pay your
money to get your outside fixed up when
you need to pay your money to get your
inside fixture
inside not outside
she dehydrated now that was a lie as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible